[music playing]
Hello my name is
Geoffrey Rush and I
play Albert Einstein the older.
I was four when
Albert Einstein died.
So everything I know about
him is more from the legend
that he became,
because he was almost
like a cult figure in a way.
Einstein was a very complex
theoretical physicist.
ALBERT EINSTEIN: What is time?
It is the key to
understanding relativity.
It is also the reason
my hair is going grey.
[laughter]
GEOFFREY RUSH: I've enjoyed it
enormously because you think
you're going to have to go in
act being a genius every day
on set.
Action!
GEOFFREY RUSH: But there's
a kind of clown-like naivety
in his persona.
(LAUGHING) Cut.
That's a cut!
GEOFFREY RUSH: Rumor has it that
he was regarded as being quite
dopey, and they
thought he might have
been a bit of a slow
starter in his childhood.
ALBERT EINSTEIN: To
truly grasp the idea
of time we must take a step
back and ask what is light?
GEOFFREY RUSH: But
his daydreaming ended
up being his greatest strength.
This is one of the great parts.
And the scale of it is so big.
[streetcar bell]
GEOFFREY RUSH: This is the
first National Geographic
fully scripted drama series.
So Ron was very keen to take
the elements of Einstein's life,
let it not fall into the
trap of being a bio pic.
RON HOWARD: Keep it
personal like that, Michael.
I really like how
conversational that was.
OK.
GEOFFREY RUSH: Because the
story of Einstein's life
sandwiched between a major
golden breakthrough period
of science from the
late 19th century
through the devastation
of two world wars.
Hey, Einstein!
Stop!
May I have your autograph, sir?
GEOFFREY RUSH: He wanted that
to have real dramatic kick.
Bruno!
Back here now.
When I grow up, I want to
be a scientist just like you.
Germany ho!
Cut!
Cutting.
GEOFFREY RUSH: The whole
series is about an epoch.
And a [inaudible] on a level
that will be exciting rather
than rigid and formal.